hey guys this is h foley and i'm kevin
ryan from the ru garbage podcast
check us out on itunes or wherever you
listen to uh podcasts
and we're here to answer the internet
yep
you rather have 50 grand straight to
your bank account
yes or half a million
in pennies and you can't convert it
well i deal in small build transit
anyway so i think i'd go with the
pennies and flex nah
take the 50 straight out the door yeah
see that
you're gonna have to get a pickup truck
to carry the pennies that's rich guy
mentality you ask anybody in my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
would you rather give up appetizers or
desserts for life
this is a no-brainer for me the [ __ ] are
you doing to me yeah what are you
talking about
uh man that's a tough one what
dude get the [ __ ] out of here with
dessert give me a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
potato skin a mozzarella stick a chicken
finger
yeah who the [ __ ] wants a brownie from
applebee's get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] the lava cake i want the tuna
tartare let me get
let me get a sampler and the check
there's nothing better than splitting
and appetizing a couple of drinks with
your lady friend
that is all classy yeah definitely [ __ ]
the desserts and that's a fat guy saying
that
if you got ten thousand dollars a day
for every day you didn't masturbate how
many days could you last
six bucks i'd end up owning money
you guys you guys you take travelers
checks you guys
what's going on here do a money order
here what's the deal if you got
10 now is it repeating is it like if i
could do it once and then or i got to do
it consistently
let me see 10 grand a day for every day
you didn't masturbate how many days
could you last once i once i do if i did
it for like a month can i start jerking
off again yeah
yeah but you just got all that cash yeah
i can make it a month easy
i could i could go i could go six months
butthole stuff doesn't count we agree on
that
it's only a jackpot can you can you milk
it can you milk it can you come in from
the back and milk it i'm still playing
with a nip everywhere
i'll take the money i could do six
months without a [ __ ] doubt
especially when you get into your 30s
it's [ __ ] slow down my sex drive is
[ __ ]
i just want somebody to scratch my back
he's like an old
he's like an old retriever would you
rather go three straight summers without
drinking or live a
full year in antarctica wait they both
suck what are you talking about how is
that good why would i want to live in
antarctica
so you can still drink technically or
three straight would you rather go three
straight summers without drinking
or live a full year in antarctica get
the snowshoe
yeah dude somebody get me a bobcat
a fox racing jacket let's [ __ ] go
this season sports is looking a little
different it's a little bit weird but
lebat blue light is gonna make sure that
their fans
hashtag gear up to make things look a
little more normal speaking of weird and
abnormal we have the ru garbage guys on
ati today
the question for them is if you could be
a character from a tv show
who would you be i would be tim riggins
because he can probably open a twist-off
can by himself
cheers
if you could be any character from a tv
show who would you be
michael knight knight rider oh [ __ ] was
that too quick i'd be looking no doubt
about it playing
playing things above the law i'd be a
pontiac
i'd be kid so you would sit on my face
all right i don't know why uh uh no for
sure
100 zack [ __ ] morris bayside high
kelly kapowski what up dude i was going
to say kelly kapowski
just to get my hands on zach
buddy just ask play him in slater
all right i'll do this one can you still
go to your barber
if he is very racist have you been to
queens
[Laughter]
and the well whiskey they serve
what's up with that you ever go anywhere
you want a whiskey i'm like it's [ __ ]
new
what are we doing well i always say
yesterday i take it
yeah yeah yeah then you're falling
asleep in the chair
uh would you rather kill 25 kittens in a
row or one
dog oh sick [ __ ]
can i get the pennies questions yeah
they start off real lighthearted
um i couldn't do either i gotta i gotta
put my foot down i could never do that
definitely definitely not 25 kittens i
mean the dog
does the dog owe me money or something
like that
if i do you should meet his wife
[Laughter]
you're not killing any animals i don't
want to but i'm playing the [ __ ] game
castle
all that stuff like i'm the guy who's
like let's kill cats you know if the
kittens is tough cats is another story
line off 50 cats
what is the fiercest animal you think
you could take in a fight
the kitten and that's questionable
[Music]
the fiercest animal i could take in a
fight i feel like if i had to if like a
pit bull was attacking me
for some reason i feel like i could i i
could get him a pit bull would run
yeah do you think yeah
i've always had a lo all right so i've
always had a big argument with my
friends when we were camping
i could i could take like a bit like a
smaller bear no
dude a smaller if i get them in a
[ __ ] if i get them under there like
a full nelson but like like a baby kind
not like a baby but like
you know we like if we light up a little
bit
i could [ __ ] slip them one dude i
wrestled for a couple of weeks
i took a little karate tiger
hit him with an elbow dropping keep it
moving
they don't have a gun or anything right
no um
i put up a fight till i saw a little
nickel like oh
i'm saying i'm saying a a little or bear
i could take
he doesn't really know what he's doing
you know he's not he's not street tough
yet you know what i
i'm a seagull i could [ __ ] up a secret
i'll tell you that you scared
shout out to atlantic city shout out to
nathan's
now this is my [ __ ] question if you
could put any
franchise restaurant in your house what
would it be
no-brainer
over at foley's mickey d's all the way
yeah i think
i would do chick-fil-a maybe not open on
sundays though
like they're not open on sunday too they
would be closed that's
corporate corporate policy you just
constantly be
judged plus my gay roommate
mickey d's all [ __ ] day and yeah just
for variety
you got to do me you got breakfast yeah
you got to do mickey d this all day too
wouldn't there [ __ ] hook it up well i
mean if it's in my apartment
i hope they [ __ ] turn the turn the
eggs on i always
this is this is a real fact i thought
but i always wanted to work at a
mcdonald's just so i can make my own
creations
you know what i mean i like how how dumb
he is he thinks he needs to work at
mcdonald's to make food
but to make like an egg mcmuffin big mac
you can do that
awesome dude there's a grocery store
it's not the same that's the whole point
of having the franchise
you got to get their buyers their
suppliers what do you mean
i always get the weird ones would you
stop would you rather kill your mom or
[ __ ] your dad
my dad in the 80s forget about it
would you stop masturbating if every
girl you wait hold on
girl you jerked off to
knew you were doing it oh man oh
god i have a couple of cousins
real chat with me thanksgiving would get
hey stacy good to see you you dirt ball
[Laughter]
and who jerks off at noon
12 1204 and then 1208 again man that's a
that's a real good one man
oh yeah i couldn't do it i couldn't face
you know what sucks about this
i couldn't do it when you asked girls
this like mostly it's been porn stars i
think rosebud
and it's just like so porn stars
we love your roses oh yeah shout out to
rb girls always like
yeah because then they just want to come
[ __ ] me oh that's great
ah that's well for them yeah you look
like a [ __ ] huge creep
yeah the thing it would be the times
that would get
like you know what i mean like
especially because you got to think you
got to have normal conversation with
them like oh
are you going to timmy's on friday night
or whatever and then it's like
you hang up the phone and then you're
like are you jerking off to me again you
know what i mean
and i'll be honest most of my you know
i'm a little bit older so most of my
uh you know talent off the bench uh it
mentally
is usually people that i don't see
anymore you know what i mean
so i might be able to get them arthur
and [ __ ]
i mean hey what am i going to bump into
betty white again
braun's almost on her way out like 6 am
on a saturday
still yeah
i'm like feidelberg i set my alarm yeah
that's
that's a tough one [ __ ] these okay if
you had to move to a different place
on the body where would you oh if you
had to move it to a different place in
the body where would i put the vagina
my vagina i know where i saw a porn one
time and it was in the back of the head
that was pretty cool
what so you could go it was a fake
obviously i mean
i hope i haven't heard from her again
so you go in the back of the head and
then into the mouth it's pretty cool i
feel like a super creep for saying that
i apologize
what's up mom i would go on the elbow
just to be different
i mean mix it up keep you on your toes
would you rather wake up to a [ __ ] or
a hundred dollars under your pillow
every morning hundred bucks no doubt
suck my own dick if i can find it
uh yeah 100 bucks forget about it yeah
what's a [ __ ] cost 50. i'm coming out
50 on top okay can we split the
difference
it is that's another one of those ones
that changes as time goes on like 22
year old music
32 year old me yeah 100 bucks dude
large bills um uh
what would you rather or would you
rather a get paid one million dollars a
year
to have to work ridiculous hours or get
paid a hundred thousand dollars a year
to do nothing
come on take the [ __ ] hundred grand
be it the [ __ ] he would do it for the
hundred bucks under the pillow
dollar dog night let's do it keep him
coming yeah the hondo
the honda 100 000 you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want the rest of the day
yeah
that's what it's all about life is all
about uh enjoying yourself
and bad hawaiian church
yeah yeah that's not even 100 dude you
can make more money you get 100 grand
you got a little bit of disposable
income you got free time you could you
know maybe a little bit coin
something going on there i don't know
but real estate baby yeah
would you rather lose your ability to
taste food or to feel sex
again please look at me what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i don't think he's
spelled sex in a long
time that was i was worried about the
corona when they i wasn't worried about
corona until they said the first sign
was that you lose
your sense of taste yeah then i was like
he wouldn't even make it through
breakfast
he'd be chewing on a piece of bacon
yeah no yeah i go sex i mean i gotta get
rid of food
what yeah bro you eat so often you have
sex
i've had chicken fingers man what are we
doing huh
give me the good stuff not that much of
an eclectic talent
yeah but sexually sexually i'm french
he's all over the board
you